we need to engage
on the terms that the left is foisting
on us i'll give you a great example of
this
great example of this yesterday a
reporter was said to have possibly
referred to our beloved press secretary
kaylee mcinanny
who makes the national heart go
pitter-patter as a
lying b-i-t-c-h
now you could hear it on the audio
we all thought it happened for a moment
this became a big story on twitter
take a listen and see what you hear
but i encourage you to read the op-ed
yes on the china vaccine research has
yeah
you've done two questions which is more
than some of your colleagues yes thank
you
okay did you hear that at the end
okay you're a lying witch
something like that is that that's
that's what i heard the first time and
this kind of went around the internet
and some
conservative publications were pushing
this and conservative blue checkmarks
were pushing this
but then someone pointed out that
it's actually if you slow it down that's
not what she said
she said okay you don't want to engage
now initially
i thought this was a ridiculous excuse
so we slowed it down
take a listen of your
colleagues yes thank you
[Applause]
as much as it pains me i tried to listen
i tried to make sure that i was
not giving this woman too much credit
kimberly halckett at al jazeera
i think that's true i actually think
when you slow it down she did say okay
you don't want to engage
it sounded like you're lying you know
what in person
and surely the press thinks that about
kayleigh baccanani but
in all fairness i don't think that's
what she said
here's the double standard when it
turned out that that's not what she said
then all the people who were spreading
this or at least a great
great number of them took it down
conservatives deleted the tweets jack
posobik eddie zipper the conservative
publications that were pushing this
around
they took it down and frankly they
didn't even assert
many of them at first that that is what
the reporter said they just raised the
question is this what the reporter said
and still they took it down i only
noticed this because
when i saw it happen i tweeted out a
joke about uh i was quoting this old
political philosophy book about how no
one should ever use a
uh course word at kaylee mcinanny and so
i but i saw the tweet was deleted and i
said okay that's good
conservatives are being fair about this
the left would never be fair
would the left ever take down their
tweets
would the left ever back off that lie
that they said about a conservative no
of course not and in fact we know that
they don't
a perfectly exemplary lie
donald trump called white supremacists
and neo-nazis very fine people at
charlottesville
that has become part of the leftist
gospel
joe biden launched his campaign on that
lie
that was the first part of the first
campaign ad to launch his campaign
and it's not true you can look one
paragraph
down trump explicitly says in
charlottesville i'm not talking about
neo-nazis and white supremacists they
should be condemned
totally and yet that lie moves on
now i like that conservatives tell the
truth i think we should continue to tell
the truth
but we should not accept any leftist
premise
that there is some sort of moral
equivalence here we should tell the
truth we should
we should not push fake news we should
not push conspiracy theories that are
not true we should tell the truth
but we should stick by our side because
these are not fair games there is no
moral equivalence here
between trump and biden between right
and left between republican and democrat
they are not the same they are not
playing by the same rules they are not
pushing for the same goods
the left wants to destroy this country
and they're doing it right now
with torches while pulling down statues
well knocking down buildings
the right is trying to build up that
country again and we should not pretend
that the stakes are any lower than that
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you